an Ohio hospital system says one of its
own former doctors prescribed
significantly excessive and potentially
fatal doses of a powerful drug to dozens
of patients who later died local
prosecutors are investigating that dr.
Mount Carmel Hospital reported at least
27 of those patients were near death and
receiving intensive care dr. William
Hewson was fired in December 23
caregivers including 14 nurses six
pharmacists and three managers were
placed on leave and Anna Werner has been
following this story and a good morning
good morning we sat down with five
people who say that their family members
died while under dr. Hugh CIL's care
their relatives had been admitted for a
wide range of conditions but attorneys
for the families say all of them died
after being given lethal doses of the
potent drug fentanyl sometimes I kind of
look at it and say I hate you from her
doorstep in Columbus Ohio
Christine Allison has a clearer view of
Mount Carmel Hospital last July
paramedics took her 44 year-old husband
Troy there he'd been in a truck accident
and was having trouble breathing him and
I and shortly after he arrived she
claims the attending doctor William
Hewson told her oh no he's dying
no I'm 99.9% sure he is brain-dead what
Allison says she didn't know was that
during his care her husband received
what her lawyers in a civil suit
described as a lethal dose of fentanyl
some three hours after arriving at Mount
Carmel Troy Allison was dead after it
was over we go down the parking garage I
looked at my daughter and I said what
the just happened and she's like mom I
have no clue Allison is now suing dr.
Hughes oh and Mount Carmel hospital
alleging the drug was intentionally
prescribed to hasten the termination of
Troy Allison's life and she's not alone
all of these people are now suing
alleging their relatives died after
receiving lethal doses of fentanyl
prescribed by dr. Hugh Sol Lynne
Marshall lost his 39 year old brother
Nick Timmons we don't think about
like what if he did they're like we
think he's brain dead Lisa Coleman
watched her 80 year old father Jim Allen
pass away it's cold Hartness it's
horrifying
Helen Young lost her husband of 46 years
Sanders the doctor come and told me he
said mr. Young's kidneys are gone his
lungs are gone he's brain dead all that
happened at once I said how in the world
did that happen
Mount Carmel Hospital is investigating
we apologize for this tragedy in a taped
statement CEO Edie Lam said that during
dr. Hugh Sol's five years at the
hospital this doctor ordered
significantly excessive and potentially
fatal doses of pain medication for at
least 27 patients who were near death
Mount Carmel fired dr. Hugh Sol and more
than 20 nurses and pharmacists have been
removed from patient care duties but dr.
Hugh slurs attorney told CBS News we
dispute the hospital's characterization
and continue to review the patient
records recently provided to them
attorney Richard Blake says the doctor
did not intend to kill anyone nor were
these mercy killings isn't anybody
watching this ship the hospital's
apology isn't good enough for Albert
bellisari
whose sixty nine year old sister Joanne
died at Mount Carmel in 2015 after also
allegedly receiving a lethal dose of
fentanyl what's keeping this from
happening whoa don't don't they have any
accountability for their actions
attorney Gerald Leesburg represents nine
families whose loved ones died including
the five in our interview it happened
for years and years and it happened with
multiple people who had to have been
getting red flags or warnings that the
orders that dr. Hugh cyl was making were
inappropriate how does this go on for
three years and nobody notices well
that's the $64,000 question we have so
many questions we don't know why do you
go to a hospital get well hopefully walk
out
not that man shouldn't be allowed to be
in in medicine at all he needs to be
prosecuted for real let's look what he
did to these feet well dr. Hugh soles
attorney as we said denies there was any
intent on the doctors part to kill
anyone but the Franklin County
Prosecutor's Office says they are
investigating the hospital said in a
statement that the way this was finally
brought to their attention was that an
employee spoke up but officials have not
explained why they did not take action
sooner very troubling story they're
raising a lot of important questions
what happened